oh we all have strange sounding but
delicious tasting food combinations that
we just
love mine is like bananas dipped in sour
cream and baco bits i got it from my mom
i thought she was nuts
she forced me to try it it was delicious
so
we're going to get help today from um
one of our dearest friends on the show
i would like to introduce him now etan
berna
hello hi ata hi i'm super excited to be
here oh my goodness
social i know i've been stalking you on
instagram i saw you at the beach and you
got your big new york apartment i'm so
excited for you
i'm a new yorker as well i know so fun
and i'm very excited for this food me
too
so since the beginning of our show etan
and i have
had this fun thing that we've done
together which is
celebrity food combination the best so a
celebrity that you know and love
has a weird food comment eitan all right
to try it let's do it okay so first up
comes from one of my favorite humans on
earth cardi b
i love cardi b i love cardi b she posted
a video of rapper offset
adding cheese dip into his ramen she was
disgusted by it but i must say it is
actually something that's classically
eaten by korean people
as a comfort food they put american
cheese into their soupy ramen
and i think it's gonna be good one of my
friends manny always does this and i
tried it once cheese and ramen is
delicious so
i didn't know that that was like yeah
but cheese on noodles not this type of
cheese but
okay let's just try that okay listen i
mean
i love a noodle so much that i feel
am i are you chopsticking it oh yeah we
are ready
see great minds thinking alike okay i'm
gonna do the like
there's nothing wrong about that nothing
wrong about it
maybe you disagree no no you like you
like it yeah
i'll take that as a guess it's really
interesting because this
taste of cheese never comes with like
the
permee ramen noodles i think i'm into it
it's like you're having like spicy
nachos with like
bouncing ramen yeah it's like it's two
different kind of feels like a college
food
dude i i still to this day can't find a
ramen i love out there as much as top
ramen
okay so next up this one i'm a little
excited for so this one comes
from rapper sweetie she posted a video
uh where she puts
ranch dressing all over her spaghetti
and tomato sauce
now one thing you're doing she
supposedly dunks it like a lot that was
why there was a whole twitter debate
over is she crazy so i'm trying to be
keep authentic okay my mouth just
watered though which is like really
weird all right
here we go that's what we do eton we do
like the celebrities deal
oh yeah fine dining at its best all
right here we go ready
i also don't hate it i don't hate to do
that
i really don't know it's actually really
good sweetie
you're a genius we're on your side of
the twitter debate like
offset yes sweetie
yes i know that's two for two-way time
not bad
the last one is pickles with
peanut butter chocolate cups okay that
is just who
is the weirdo possible genius who came
up with this combo the one and only
selena gomez
she told bon appetit that pickles with
reese's peanut butter cups are
supposedly delicious she said it's a
combination that just works for so many
reasons i don't know those reasons but
we may find out do you know what's so
funny eitan
the power of celebrity i was like this
seems like
weird and when i said selena gomez oh
okay well
maybe cause it's selena i'm thinking
like a sandwich like do you like a
little pickle sandwich oh
see etan that's why you're you i would
have never thought to sammy
cheers all right cheers love you
it's not terrible
hey
um this one i'm not sure i got
no out with the pickles in with the cup
the peanut butter cup is so good oh yeah
but
half sour pickles are like my favorite
thing on the planet
i love pickles too and i love reese's
peanut butter cups so like
they're not together yeah no they're
they're not a match made in heaven i
didn't think there wasn't
a thing in the world that selena gomez
couldn't convince me
but we found it i i we found it and
hopefully
we might pick her brain one day yes
that'll be fun well i love this
aton can we please do this again asap
and get more weird celebrity food combos
i'm always down you know me
oh good dayton i love you